GREAT SPECIFICITY BREAKING NEWS
COMING UP.
TONIGHT, WE ARE WITNESSING A
WHITE HOUSE AND FOOD CRISIS MODE
.
THEY ARE PANICKING IN THE WEST
WING BIDEN A VISIBLY SHAKEN
AFTER THE APPOINTMENT OF A
SPECIAL COUNSEL TO INVESTIGATE
THE CLASSIFIED TOP SECRET OBAMA
AIR DOCUMENTS THAT QUOTE TURNED
UP AT THREE SEPARATE UNSECURED
LOCATIONS.
THAT INCLUDES THAT JOE BIDEN'S
GARAGE IN DELAWARE.
NEXT TO HIS ADVANTAGE GROW THAT.
DON'T WORRY, THE GARAGE WAS
LOCKED.
AT LEAST MOST OF THE TIME TAKE
LOOK THERE'S THE GARAGE RIGHT
THERE.
THE SCANDAL GETS WORSE BY THE
DAY.
COMING UP GOOGLE TO GET TO A
SHOCKING TIMELINE THAT IS A VER
FOR BOTH JOE BIDEN AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
HIS DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
WE WILL FOLLOW THE MONEY BACK T
CHINA AND ALSO BACK AGAIN AND W
HAVE A SPECIAL REPORT BREAKING
NEWS ABOUT TEN MINUTES AGO FROM
JOHN SOLOMON.
THE GREAT ONE MARK LEVAN HE WIL
WEIGH IN ON ALL OF THIS.
GERALDO WILL BE IN THE HANNITY
HOTSEAT TONIGHT TO OFFER HIS
DEFENSE OF HIS GOOD FRIEND JOE
BIDEN.
FRANKLY, THERE IS NO DEFENSIVE.
DEVON AND WILL JOIN US TONIGHT
WITH A REACTION TO WHAT WAS
RELEASED TODAY THE LATEST BATCH
OF TWITTER FILES THAT DIRECTLY
INVOLVES THE FORMER CHAIRMAN
ADAM SHAFT AND EVERYONE IN
BETWEEN.
IT WILL PROVE THAT WE WERE
VINDICATED ON ALL OF OUR
REPORTING AS IT RELATES TO THE
RUSSIAN HOAX.
LET'S BEGIN TONIGHT IN
WILMINGTON, DELAWARE.
AT JOE BIDEN'S PRIVATE RESIDENCE
.
FOR MORE THAN TWO DECADES, JOE
WOULD JELL AND HUNTER CALLED
THIS HOUSE A HOME.
AS IT TURNS OUT, BIDEN'S MANSIO
ALSO WAS HOUSING NUMEROUS
CLASSIFIED TOP SECRET DOCUMENTS
FROM HIS TIME AS VICE PRESIDENT
THAT HE APPARENTLY STOLE FROM
THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE WHEN HE
LEFT AND EARLY 2017.
THE DOCUMENTS WERE RECENTLY
LOCATED IN BIDEN'S PERSONAL
LIBRARY.
EVEN HIS GARAGE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE PICTURE.
WIDE OPEN.
HE SAID THE DOOR WAS LOCKED.
NOT ALL THE TIME.
SAID THAT IN A TWENTYTWENTY
CAMPAIGN VIDEO.
PRESUMABLY THE DOCUMENTS WERE
LOCATED IN THOSE CARDBOARD BOXE
PICTURED RIGHT THERE.
ACCORDING TO JOE BIDEN, IT'S NO
A BIG DEAL.
PEOPLE KNOW HE TAKES THEM
SERIOUSLY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> CLASSIFIED MATERIALS NEXT TO
YOUR CORVETTE?
WHAT WERE YOU THINKING?
>> I GET A CHANCE TO SPEAK ON
ALL OF THIS WILL EXAMINE AS I
SAID EARLIER THIS WEEK, MY
CORVETTE IS IN A LOCKED GARAGE.
IT'S NOT LIKE THEY'RE SITTING I
THE STREET.
>> AS WELL AS MY CORVETTE.
AS I SAID EARLIER THIS WEEK,
PEOPLE KNOW I TAKE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS AND MATERIALS
SERIOUSLY.
>> THAT'S LAUGHABLE.
PEOPLE WHO TAKE CLASSIFIED
MATERIALS AT SERIOUSLY DON'T
STASH THEM IN A GARAGE FOR YEARS
.
A PRIVATE GARAGE ACCESSED BY ON
GUY NAME HUNTER BIDEN AND GOD
KNOWS WHO MOUNTS.
DURING JOE BIDEN'S AT FOUR YEAR
AS A PRIVATE CITIZEN AND DURING
HIS MANY VISITS AS PRESIDENTS,
WE HAVE NO IDEA THAT THIS TIME
YOU ENTER THAT HOUSE.
THERE ARE NO VISITOR LOGS OR
SECURITY LOGS.
NOTHING.
THEY'VE BEEN HIDING IT FOR TWO
YEARS FROM THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SINCE HE'S BEEN PRESIDENT.
ACCORDING TO A VISIBLY NERVOUS
PIERRE THE BIDEN WAREHOUSE IS
THE MOST TRANSPARENT
ADMINISTRATION IN HISTORY.
THAT'S THE CLAIM.
>> WHEN WHAT A WHITE HOUSE
RELEASE A LOG OF IT VISITORS IT
TO THE WILMINGTON MARK.
>> YOU ASKED THIS QUESTION OR
YOUR COLLEAGUES HAVE BEFORE,
LET'S NOT FORGET WHAT WE DID
HERE IN THIS WHITE HOUSE.
WE INSTITUTED SOMETHING THAT TH
LAST OF MINISTRATION GOT RID OF
IT WHICH IS OF PUTTING OUT THE
WHITE HOUSE MAKING SURE THERE
WAS A WHITE HOUSE LOG EXTENSIVE
IT WHITE HOUSE LOG.
AT THE PEOPLE GOT TO SEE--
[INDISCERNIBLE]
>> UNSECURED CLASSIFIED MATERIAL
.
>> AGAIN, I'M TELLING YOU WE DI
SOMETHING THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION GOT RID OF WHICH
IS INSTITUTING THE WHITE HOUSE
LOGS.
DID YOU ASK THE LAST
MINISTRATION WHERE THEY GOT RID
OF THAT?
BE BACK LET'S GO [INDISCERNIBLE]
>> DELAWARE RESIDENTS OF?
I WAS CALLED THE GENTLEMAN WHO
WANTED TO ASK A QUESTION NOT
RELATED TO THIS.
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE BECAUSE 40
PERCENT OF HIS TIME AS
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN OUTSIDE THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THAT THEY HAVE
NEVER RELEASED ANY OF THE
VISITOR LOGS A.
THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE CARE SO
MUCH ABOUT TRANSPARENCY, THEY
ATTENDED THE HIDE THE DOCUMENT
SCANDAL NOW FOR MONTHS.
FOR A WILD, BIDEN'S AT DOJ HAS
DOJ FROM THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH O
HIS EXECUTIVE BRANCH MORE THAN
HAPPY TO OBLIGE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
TIMELINE.
LAST AUGUST AFTER PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND INVITED FEDERAL
OFFICIALS TO HIS HOME TO REVEAL
PRESIDENTIAL DOCUMENTS.
THEY WENT IN THE VERY ROOM WHER
THEY LATER FOUND DOCUMENTS
DURING A RAID.
THEY HAD IT THAT DAY.
THEY COULD'VE TAKEN IT THAT DAY.
THEY CALLED AND SAID PUT A
PADLOCK ON THE ROOM WE WENT INTO
.
WHERE THESE QUOTE DOCUMENTS
EXISTED.
THAT REQUEST WAS GRANTED.
IF THEY PUT A PADLOCK ON IT.
THE FBI INSTEAD OF KNOCKING ON
THE DOOR AND AND WE GO BACK IN
THE ROOM, THEY RATED MARA LAGO.
THEY SEIZED AT THE DOCUMENTS BY
FORCE.
THEY HAD ACCESS TO PREVIOUSLY I
THAT ROOM.
IN SEPTEMBER, BIDEN PRORATED
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLED
HIM IRRESPONSIBLE ON 60 MINUTES.
IN THE NOVEMBER 2, 6 DAYS BEFOR
THE ALL IMPORTANT MIDTERMS, A
TROVE OF TOP SECRET CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS WERE FOUND IN BIDEN'S
PRIVATE OFFICE IN THE DOJ WAS
NOTIFIED THEN.
THERE WAS NO SUBSEQUENT RATE OF
BIDEN'S PRIVATE OFFICES OR HOME
AND BIDEN AND GARLAND IN BIDEN'
AT DOJ SAID NOTHING TO YOU THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE INFORMATION YOU
SHOULD HAVE HAD BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
TWO WEEKS LATER, NOVEMBER 18,
ONLY INVESTIGATING DONALD TRUMP.
NOT JOE BIDEN.
IT WAS NOT UNTIL TODAY THAT
GARLAND APPOINTED A SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO INVESTIGATE BIDEN.
AT THE WHITE HOUSE CONTINUES TO
CLAIM THE PRESIDENT HAD NO IDEA
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS OR HOUSED
IN MULTIPLE UNSECURED LOCATIONS.
DONALD TRUMP HAS WE POINTED OUT
YESTERDAY HAD EVERY RIGHT TO
DECLASSIFY THERE'S NEWS THAT
PROCESS IF THERE IS NO LEGAL
PROCESS.
RAY MEANS HE HAS TO FOLLOW.
THAT IS NOT SOMETHING A VICE
PRESIDENT HAS.
AS JONATHAN TURLEY POINTS OUT,
THE CLAIM IS PROBABLY A BOLDFAC
LIVE.
AT LEAST SOMEONE MOVED MULTIPLE
TIMES.
WE WILL FIND OUT IN TIME.
THAT'S BECAUSE OF THE YEAR
INVITED CENTER WHERE MUCH OF TH
MATERIALS TURNED UP DID NOT OPE
THEIR DOORS UNTIL 2018.
THAT MEANS OVER A YEAR AFTER
BIDEN LEFT THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE
.
WHERE WHERE THE DOCUMENTS STORE
BEFORE THEM AND WHO MOVED THEM
AROUND AND WHO MIGHT'VE SAW THEM
?
SPEAKING OF WHICH, THE EUROPEAN
POLITICAL CENTER NAMED AFTER JO
BIDEN WAS PROBABLY ONE OF THE
WORST PLACES ON EARTH TO STORE
TOP-SECRET DOCUMENT.
>> UNIVERSITY OF PENNSYLVANIA
PAY VERY CLOSE ATTENTION TO THE
MONEY.
OF COLLECTED A WHOPPING
$67 MILLION BETWEEN 2013 AND
2019 FROM A VAST MAJORITY OF
THAT MONEY NEARLY $50 MILLION.
47.7 MILLION LOWERED IN DURING
BIDEN'S LUCRATIVE RAIN AT THE U
PENN BIDEN CENTER.
GET THIS IN A 2016 E-MAIL
UNCOVERED ON THE VERY REAL
LAPTOP OF HUNTER BIDEN, HIS
AGENT REFERENCES THE CREATION O
THE U PENN CENTER WHILE ALSO
DISCUSSING HUNTER'S PLANS FOR
WEALTH CREATION.
KEEP IN MIND ALSO REVEALED A
PLANNER FOR THE BIDENS TOO SHAR
OFFICE SPACE AT THE U PENN BIDE
CENTER WITH INDIVIDUALS FROM TH
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY.
IN ONE E-MAIL REQUEST TO GET
KEYS IT MADE FOR NATIONALS.
REMEMBER PRIOR HUNTER WASN'T
RAKING IN MILLIONS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS FROM CHINESE FOREIGN
NATIONALS INCLUDING PROCEEDS
FROM THE MULTIBILLION-DOLLAR
DOLLAR DL INCORPORATED WITH THE
BANK OF CHINA TEN DAYS AFTER
HUNTER JOINED HIS FATHER THE
VICE PRESIDENT ON THAT TRIP TO
BEIJING ON AIR FORCE TO END UP
COURSE ANOTHER MASSIVE DEAL WIT
THE CHINESE ENERGY CONGLOMERATE
DON'T FORGET THE $5 MILLION NO
INTEREST AT FORGIVABLE LOAN.
DON'T FORGET THE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS CHINESE
NATIONAL SHOPPING SPREE.
IF ALL OF THIS ISN'T ENOUGH, IN
FEBRUARY OF 2022, AFTER GETTING
MILLIONS IN DONATIONS FROM CHINA
, THE UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA SUCCESSFULLY
LOBBIED THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
TO END A COUNTERESPIONAGE
PROGRAM AGAINST A BEIJING'S
GROWING INFLUENCE.
KEEP IN MIND CHINA IS OUR
COUNTRY AMERICA'S NUMBER ONE
GEOPOLITICAL FILE AND NOW THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE HE IS IT CALLING FOR
INVESTIGATIONS INTO BIDEN'S
SPECIAL RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA.
>> COURAGE TO PENNSYLVANIA WHER
IT IS BIDEN CENTER IS WHERE ALL
THE CHINESE MONEY GOES TO FUND
ALL THE BIDEN INITIATIVES IT.
THEY ENCOURAGE THE FBI TOO DRAW
UP THAT CHINA INITIATIVE
INVESTIGATION.
WHAT ELSE ARE THEY INFLUENCING
THIS ADMINISTRATION TO DO?
WHAT ELSE IS CHINA AND
INFLUENCING THIS ADMINISTRATION
AND THE BIDEN FAMILY THIS IS
VERY CONCERNING?
WAS SENDING A LETTER TO PENN
REQUESTING DOCUMENTS RELATED TO
THE CHINESE DONATIONS WE WANT A
LIST INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED
WHOEVER WAS INVOLVED IN
SOLICITING DONATIONS FROM CHINA.
WITH ALL COMMUNICATIONS.
>> THE FACT THAT TOP-SECRET
CLASSIFIED COMPARTMENTED
DOCUMENTS WERE DISCOVERED IN TH
U PENN BIDEN CENTER IS MORE THA
A LITTLE STRANGE APPEARED TO TH
FACT THAT HUNTER BIDEN COULD'VE
EASILY ACCESSED ALL THOSE
DOCUMENTS IS MORE THAN A LITTLE
CONCERNING IN THE FACT WE HAVE
NO IDEA HOW MANY CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS REMAIN IN BIDEN'S
HOUSE, GARAGE, OFFICE IS BEYOND
TROUBLING TO SAY THE LEAST.
AT THE FACT CHINA RUSSIA UKRAIN
IN A MULTITUDE OF OTHER
COUNTRIES PAID HUNTER AND THAT
THE FAMILY SYNDICATE MILLIONS
WITHOUT ANY EXPERIENCE IS BEYON
ANYONE'S IMAGINATION AND BY THE
WAY WE NEED ANSWERS BECAUSE IT
WAS JOE BIDEN HIMSELF I NEVER
WANT TO TALK TO HUNTER ABOUT MY
DEALINGS.
THERE'S REALLY ONLY ONE WAY TO
KNOW IF ALL THE CLASSIFIED
MATERIAL HAS BEEN TURNED OVER.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT IS A.
I'LL GIVE YOU A HAND TO.
I'VE GOT NO PROBLEM DOING THIS
AND MORE LAGO.
>> IF THIS IS A SERIOUS
INVESTIGATION, IT IS TIME OF AL
OF BIDEN'S PROPER PRIVATE
PROPERTIES TO BE RATED.
TOMORROW MORNING WOULD BE A GOO
TIME.
OTHERWISE OUR TWO-TIERED SYSTEM
OF JUSTICE WILL HAVE REARED ITS
UGLY HEAD YET AGAIN AND